hey guys so I'm really upset because
just as I was about to update to iOS 8
my wife I went out so guess where I am
oh that's right at the Apple Store to
steal their frickin Wi-Fi because it's
really really fast here we go let's do
it I remember being in Norway actually
with Edie and we were updating - I think
it was probably iOS don't remember it's
Terry checking for updates
checking for update download and install
is a gig it's a gig we're downloading
you'll be notified when the update has
been downloaded and ready but I want to
do it now it's downloading look if I
think they're happy they're happy
they're excited they're are excited beat
this 1.1 gig but it needs four gigs I
want to make a Genius Bar appointment
it's all working day is my appointment
about 33 minutes remaining this is
happening
Wi-Fi went out oh my gosh losing my mind
losing min my home again I gotta OSI
wait Iowa I oh s I wait iOS 8.0
preparing update it's been taking about
an hour so what's your struggle with iOS
8 I don't have enough room on my own I
got rid of every single text thread I
got rid of all of my music every single
picture and video and I still don't have
it it could it be really interesting to
see how people handle with a 16 gig
phone with the new iPhone 6 but that's
not it's not gonna be enough space
what's up his room I don't look I got
rid of everything on my phone and I find
the of enough space haha how do I go to
everything I look all my apps I kept
like five apps really oh oh my gosh mine
is still downloading it's an hour and a
half later preparing update everything's
gone it's now time to install install
now oh well let me 11:35 you took quite
a long time I can't believe that the
iPhone 6 will be out in today's I am
preparing you guys because I'm going to
do a charity auction of my old phone but
stay tuned for that tomorrow here we go
the installation process is happening
now update complete
continue oh my gosh did it even update
like is this new but yes it looks new
all the hell's app let's check it out
guys the health app let's do this I have
not been healthy today eat a medical ID
can be accessed from my gosh this is
crazy this is awesome good work
is there like a body measurement of I'm
a pig what else is new
tips
should I like it all right I liked it
all right I like it
here's the new stills look at these
these look great
this one looks grilled nice and a Polly
alright guys so if I always ate
installed I'm pretty excited and it's so
hot outside right now that my phone
actually was overheating and it wouldn't
even let me turn it back on so there's a
few more days until the iPhones out I'm
pretty excited let me know what you guys
think and if you're gonna just fight
about Android verse iPhone it's just you
know keep it clean I'll see you guys
tomorrow and I will let you know as soon
as I have more information about the
charity auction giveaway I'm pretty
excited I haven't figured out what
charity I'm going to donate to yet so
yeah stay tuned for that I'll see you
guys later